useful rebuttal by a president fighting
for his political survival Ecuador's
Guillermo lasso denied all wrongdoing in
the first day of impeachment proceedings
against him instead offering a searing
critique of opposition lawmakers
today I am here on this podium in my
defense and respecting your oversight
role but I have also come here to say
the following to my accusers I accuse
you I accuse you of having abandoned
your role as legislators you are now
anti-legislators of this Republic
because you do not create laws and
instead you destroy them the former
Banker is accused of corruption having
allowed the embezzlement of public funds
through contracts that a state-owned oil
Transfer Company
but those making the claims against them
are using the trial to paint the picture
of a failed presidency that goes beyond
this specific case president
lasso you are not above the law you have
exceeded all the limits of what the
Constitution says which is why today you
are sitting accused in a trial lasso
barely survived the first impeachment
vote less than a year ago following
weeks of mass protests against the cost
of living the president who has a 17
approval rating and opinion polls has
presided over a worsening economic
situation and a wave of drug trafficking
related violence
a super majority of 92 out of 137
lawmakers is needed to secure his
removal but at any point before the vote
lasso could dissolve Congress and
Trigger early elections he would then
govern by decree for six months while
elections take place outside the
National Assembly hundreds gathered in
support and against the president
their deaths everywhere safety is the
worst in Latin America what is happening
in Ecuador we've never been like this
before the right needs to step aside
this is a wicked impeachment trial it
only shows resentment and immorality the
president defended himself very well we
are afraid of becoming Cuba or Venezuela
we don't want a return to socialism
yet a coalition to impeach lasso crosses
ideological boundaries from the leftist
union for Hope party of former president
Rafael Correa to the right-wing social
Christians that until recently were on
the president's side which shows just
how unpopular this government has become
the proceedings will continue through
Wednesday with a possible vote coming as
soon as Saturday Alessandra Al Jazeera